CHET HAASE: Hi, I'm Chet Haase
from the Android team at
Google, where I work on graphics
and animations.
And today I wanted to talk a
little bit more about ListView
animations, which I talked about
in a previous episode.
This is another episode in a
series that I like to call,
You're Doing It Wrong.
So this is another item related
to the last one where
there is a need to understand
how views are
actually used by ListView.
ListView recycles views, which
means that when those views
are not on the screen, it may
use that view to hold
different content.
And you need to be aware of
that, especially when you're
running animations,
so that you're not
animating the wrong thing.
So to demonstrate that, let's
take a look at a little demo.
So we have this demo that I
call ListView Animations.
And there's a long
list, and quite a
boring one, of cheeses.
Now, as I click on these
items, they're going to
automatically fade
out and then be
removed from the adapter.
And the ListView is going to
update itself, and that cheese
will no longer exist.
So we can scroll someplace.
We can delete this one.
We can see the fadeout.
And then the ListView
collapses around it.
So all of that is good.
But what happens if we delete
a couple of these and then
fling the list?
Hopefully, you can see
this on the screen.
But what you should be able to
see is, as I'm flinging the
list, there seem to be items
that have nothing to do with
the ones that I clicked on
that are being removed.
And this is because we're
running a fade animation on a
view, which has since been
recycled and is being used for
different content.
Now, that doesn't mean
that the wrong
item is being deleted.
But it does mean that the wrong
view is being animated.
So what happens is we
click on an item.
It starts running a fade
animation on it.
We fling the list.
That view is off the screen.
It gets reused for different
content.
The view continues
fading, because
it's the same instance.
It's the same object inside.
So it continues fading,
even though it now
shows different content.
And then when that animation is
done, then we automatically
delete the original item.
So the data is still intact.
That's fine.
But the visual experience on
the screen is just weird.
We don't want to do
stuff like that.
So there's a couple of ways that
you can account for this.
And I want to talk about
those today.
So for one thing, you could
use this item called View
Property Animator.
And as of Jelly Bean-- actually,
both of these ways
of compensating for this are
in the Jelly Bean release.
One is to use View Property
Animator, which internally
tells the system, hey, I'm not
done with this view yet.
So just let me run my
animation in peace.
So if I'm using that for the
animations and then I do the
fling operation, you'll see
that there is no more
disruption on the screen.
Nothing is being faded out in
the new views that we're
seeing on the screen, because
we are persisting the views
that had the animations
running on them.
So, basically, we're grabbing it
and saying, you know what?
I have a lock on this view.
Don't recycle it yet, because
I'm in the middle of using it.
If you don't want to use View
Property Animator, another way
to get the same capability,
again, in the Jelly Bean
release is to use this
new property
called Transient State.
So you can call this
method, saying, set
has Transient State.
And that tells us you're in the
middle of using it, and we
won't recycle it until
you tell us to.
So, again, we delete
some things.
We fling the list.
And we have no disruptive
experience on the screen,
because we know that you are
still using those views that
you are fading out.
So interesting demo, more
interesting code.
Let's take a look at that.
So we have this class called
ListView Animations.
We create the check boxes and
the list view and the adapter,
all that stuff.
The interesting part
is down here.
What happens when we
click on an item?
So when we click on it,
we're immediately
going to run this animation.
But how we run it depends on
which of those check boxes we
check at the top for using View
Property Animator, or
Transient State, or
none of those.
So in the none of those case,
basically, we wind up in this
code down here.
We say, OK, I'm going to create
an Object Animator.
And we're going to animate.
In a previous episode, we saw
some basics on how to use
Object Animator.
We use a target object.
We use a target property.
We're going to animate the alpha
property on that view.
And we're going to animate it to
zero from whatever value it
has right now, which happens
to be one, fully opaque.
It usually is.
So we create the animation.
We set a duration of 1,000.
Way too long for this operation,
but for the
purposes of this demo, I wanted
you to actually be able
to see the animation and the
artifact as it was happening.
The transient state
is not checked.
So we're going to skip this
code here, which is the
interesting part, which
we'll get to later.
We're going to add a listener
so that we can actually
restore these things later
and then remove it
from the data set.
So on animation end, when this
nice, little fade animation
out to zero ends, we're going
to go in here and actually
remove it from the
list of cheeses.
Notify the data set change,
restore the alpha property,
which is always important to do
with fading animations, and
then we're done.
And then we start
the animation.
So life is good unless that
view got scrolled off the
screen after the animation
started, in which case, the
view has been reassigned to
different content when you get
that disruptive experience
that we saw earlier.
So the two workarounds
for it are to use a
View Property Animator.
So if you checked that box at
the top of this demo, then
instead of using Object Animator
to animate that view,
we're going to use View
Property Animator.
And we do that by calling
code much like this.
We say view.animate.
That returns the instance of the
View Property Animator for
that specific view.
Set duration, again, we want an
unusually long duration for
this animation just for the
purposes of this demo.
And then we're going to animate
alpha to a value of
zero from its current value,
which happens to be one.
And when this animation
finishes, it's going to have
an end action, which does
something remarkably similar
to what we saw before.
It's going to remove the item
from the cheese list, notify
data set changed, and restore
the alpha property.
And we're done.
No special magic to
work around this.
Instead, internally, we're doing
the right thing to tell
the ListView, don't recycle this
view yet, because I'm in
the middle of using it.
And then when that animation is
done, it unsets that flag,
and that view can be recycled
appropriately.
The alternate way to do it, if
you're not using View Property
Animator, you can have access
to this exact same
functionality by calling set
has transient state.
So if you checked that other
box at the top of the demo
that said Transient State,
then we will say, set has
transient state.
So when you click on the item,
we're automatically going to
flag that item in the ListView
as having transition state,
which means the ListView will
not recycle that item until
you tell it it's OK.
So we're going to set
has transient state.
We're going to run the same
exact animation as before.
But OnAnimation end is going to
run this little additional
bit of code, which restores
the transient state to its
default state of false.
So you click on the item.
We start running the
Object Animator.
It's fading out to View.
It's all happy.
You've set transient
state on it.
We fling the list.
That view still exists.
Even though it's now off-screen
and you can't see
it anymore, it's not being used
for other content, which
is really the key to making
this animation
actually work correctly.
So ListView Animations, if you
want to do them right, be
aware of that transient state.
And don't try to animate stuff
that's going to be recycled
with other content.
Thanks.